un journal j'ai une amie qui est venu
dormir chez moi quelques nus le temps de
louer son appartement à des touristes
allemands
sauf que ça fait trois mois et elle est
toujours là je sais pas comment lui dire
que j'aimerais bien récupérer mon lit
pardon je te réveilles tu fais quoi
bah c'est pour que ce soit fait oui
c'est beaucoup mieux pour qu'on système
immunitaire beaucoup mieux dans son
appartement et aussi à l'intérieur de
toi je suis d'accord qu'un petit peu de
changements ne me ferait pas de mal mais
bon je passe certaine que ce soit en la
laissant envahir ma zone de confort que
je vais réussir à en sortir tu sais où
elle est la machine à café hd vendus ça
ne faisait pas du bien café le matin
j'ai fait du talent un monde si tu veux
certain temps un peu comme chez toi pas
c'est juste que j'aime bien café le
matin c'est pas top pour les intestins
tu sais pas ce que secte et enfin je
sais que le matin tu alors c'est mon ami
et j'apprécie qu'elle soit tout ce que
j'apprécie qu'elle soit tout ce que je
ne suis tout ce que je ne suis pas
dynamique souris dynamique souris
souriante à hyper envahissante et
surtout super chiant tu te dis quoi rien
tu as dit j'étais chute j'ai rien dit
yao quinson qu'elle sorti de ma bouche
pour le coup
[Musique]
tu fais quoi j'essaie de terminer ma
page fait voir pour ne pas avoir à dire
ce que je pense pas lui dire j'invente
des excuses pour retrouver mon espace
vital et pouvoir ne rien faire en toute
tranquillité tu crois qu éventuellement
ce que je me disais peut-être que ce
week end fut en fait terminé tu sais que
c'est exactement le même texte dans
toutes les éditions
je me doutais que ce week-end je
pourrais rentrer chez toi parce que je
dois y héberger mon frère et régions
chez moi je lui sous loue mon
appartement n'y a aucun problème comme
ça il vient pas nous envahir et si c'est
fou cette histoire parce que en fait
c'est l'histoire de télémaque
qui est le fils de pénélope et du lycée
est en fait une lisse il est parti faire
la guerre de troie ya quasiment vingt
ans donc ça veut dire que télémaque en
fait il n'a même pas connu